bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo mise au point
sur les denisot via qui était l'homme de
denisova alors les denisot via c'est une
découverte qui a été annoncé dans une
revue scientifique prestigieuse en 2010
et c'est une découverte qui a fait
l'effet d'une bombe puisque on va se
rendre compte que nota notamment on
avait complètement raté cette espèce
humaine je le dire du point de vue
fossiles elle nous avait complètement
échappé mais qu'en plus elle a contribué
au gène d'homo sapiens alors la
découverte faite en 2010 nous présente
quelques reste très fragmentaire à peine
identifiables j'ai envie de dire on a
quelques doses on a quelques bouts de
dents mais ces bouts de dorel ont
quelque chose de néandertaliens
notamment elles sont très grosses qu'il
ya un truc qu'on retrouve chez
néandertaliens elles sont plus grosses
probablement que chez néandertal mais
quand même elles ont ce petit quelque
chose de néandertaliens mail aux
problèmes qu'ils ont eu à l'époque c'est
que ils ont pas réussi à identifier ce
que c'était à partir des peu de fossiles
qu'ils avaient par contre ce qu'il
savait c'est que déjà la grotte de
denisova se trouvant en sibérie
profondément vraiment dans la partie est
de la sibérie et même très au nord donc
il fait très froid il y avait des
chances que des gènes soient préservés
dans ces fossiles et d'autres parce
qu'il savait c'est que ben en 2010 on
venait de finir de séquencer le génome
de néandertal donc on pouvait analyser
les gènes de ces fragments d'ossements
de denisot vient pour pouvoir les
identifier et notamment vérifier qu'il
s'agit de néandertal parce que la grotte
de denisova vu où elle est située en
sibérie elle est quand même elle serait
quand même en marge de la zone de
distribution de néandertal donc à
l'époque il se disait si on a du
néandertal à cet endroit là c'est quand
même vachement loin de là l'air de
répartition normal de néandertal c'est à
dire l'europe et le moyen-orient donc
ils font les analyses génétiques et là
ils se rendent compte que ce n'est ni
néandertal ni homo sapiens il s'agit
d'une troisième espèce humaine donc un
être humain presque moderne j'ai envie
de dire il s'agit d'une troisième espèce
humaine qui était complètement passé
sous le radar donc ça c'est l' annonce
qui a fait l'effet d'une bombe on est
passé toutes ces années à côté de
l'homme de denisova donc ça ça a été le
premier la première grosse découverte en
2010 de se rendre compte qu'il y avait
une troisième espèce humaine qui avaient
cohabité avec neandertal et homo sapiens
et ça ça a été confirmé par des
datations des études ultérieures qui ont
été faites et qui ont montré que denisot
va a vécu quelque part entre 30000 et
300 mille ans avec des grosses marges
d'erreur quand même mais c'est en plein
dans la période où cohabitent et déjà
néandertal est homo sapiens et comme au
même moment on commence aussi à se
rendre compte que il y a eu des
événements d'hybridation entre sapiens
et néandertal et ben on a commencé à se
demander et dis donc est-ce que denisot
va se serait pas aussi [ __ ] avec homo
sapiens et bien au fil des découvertes
qui ont été faites et notamment des
analyses génétiques qui ont été faites
après la découverte de l'homme de
denisova eh bien on s'est rendu compte
que oui il y a eu des hybridations
possible entre sapiens et l'homme de
denisova est pas un peu d'hybridation
dans les populations d'asie du sud-est
et d'indonésie on parle de 4 à 6% de
gênes de denise via qui aurait été
transmis à homo sapiens dont kylie a
effectivement une
contribution non négligeable assez
similaire au final à ce qu'on retrouve
deux gènes de néandertal dans les
populations européennes
donc il y a eu d hybridation entre
denisot via et homo sapiens et grâce aux
gènes de denisova qu'on retrouve chez
les populations humaines modernes on
arrive à reconstituer une aire
géographique
hypothétique de denisot va donc qui
passe par la grotte de denisova en
sibérie évidemment mais qui va aussi
jusqu'au tibet et même jusqu'en asie du
sud est et ce qui est de très
intéressant et bien c'est que les
découvertes fossiles qui ont succédé à
ces analyses génétiques ont confirmé en
fait cette distribution puisqu'on a
retrouvé une mandibule de denisot va
formellement identifié grâce aux gènes
on a retrouvé cette mandibules au tibet
et c'est une mandibule de denisova et
tout récemment une équipe notamment
composée de chercheurs français vient de
retrouver en asie du sud-est des dents
qui appartiennent bel et bien à denisot
donc c'est vraiment tout récemment qu'on
vient de confirmer grâce aux fossiles
l'air de répartition hypothétique qui
avait été supposé basée uniquement sur
les gènes et ça c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire de voir à quel point la
génétique et la paléontologie
travaillent main dans la main pour
essayer de reconstituer cette aire de
répartition géographique de denisova bon
maintenant ces restes fossiles aussi
dispersés qu'il soit dans tout l'est de
l'asie ne nous renseigne pas beaucoup
sur la lure de denisova à quoi
ressemblait denisot va on peut pas
vraiment reconstitué avec ce qu'on avait
jusque là un portrait robot de ce à quoi
denisova pouvait ressembler on n'a que
des restes très fragmentaire 7
mandibules du tibet étant le plus gros
fossiles qu'on ait de denisot va alors à
quoi ressemblait denisot va bas on
n'avait que les gènes en fait pour
décider à quoi ressemblait denisova et
ses gènes comme je les dis ressemblent
beaucoup à ceux de néandertal néandertal
et denisot va son cousin sont très
proches parents beaucoup plus qu'ils ne
le sont d'homo sapiens donc on était en
droit de supposer que denisot va
ressembler à néandertal en se basant
uniquement sur les jette donc il aurait
pu avoir une allure franchement
néandertalienne du point de vue
morphologique notamment les gros bourgs
les suces orbitaire le front fuyant le
menton fuyant contrairement à homo
sapiens qui a un front verticale et à
menton bien prononcé et pas de bourg les
suces orbitaire donc ça c'est ce qu'on
pouvait supposer à partir des gènes de
denisot va mais en 2021 est annoncé la
découverte du crâne d'arbine donc le
crâne d'arbine qui a été découvert en
chine est un crâne quasiment complet et
qui contient une dent et cette dent est
très similaire aux dents de denisova
notamment de par sa taille comme je
voulais dit denisot va avait des dents
très grosse donc ce crâne d'arbine qui a
servi à la création d'une nouvelle
espèce du genre homo homo longhi l'homme
dragon bien ce crâne d'arbine pourrait
en fait être un crâne d'hommes de
denisova alors comment on le sait est
bien parce que là dedans qui est
préservée sur le crâne d'arbine est très
similaire aux dents qu'on retrouve sur
la mandibule du tibet et 7 mandibules du
tibet a été identifiée formellement
comme appartenant à denisova d'après les
analyses génétiques donc par association
le crâne d'arbine est associée à la
mandibule du tibet qui est elle même
associée à l'homme de denisova de par
les analyses génétiques donc on n'a
jamais fait des analyses génétiques sur
le crâne d'arbine mais par association
il est possiblement identifiables comme
appartenant à l'homme de denisova et ça
ça à plusieurs implications et la
première c'est qu'on peut désormais
donner à portrait robot de l'homme de
denisova donc l'homme de denisova s'il
s'agit bien de homologué et bien
ressembler à ceci on peut désormais
donner une représentation graphique de
la lure de l'homme de denisova et
effectivement ils ressemblent à l'homme
de néandertal avec son front légèrement
fuyant bourlès us orbitaire et l'absence
de menton donc ça déjà c'est une
première grande découverte qui a été
permise par le crâne d'arbine la
deuxième grande découverte qui a été
permise grâce à la découverte du crâne
d'arbine c'est que désormais le l'homme
de denisova est associé enfin un nom
scientifique
un binôme line est un comme on les
appelle donc tels que pour l'homme
moderne homo sapiens pour l'homme de
néandertal homo neandertalensis et bien
désormais l'homme de denisova peut être
rappeler aux mots longue mais ça
s'arrête pas là parce que l'histoire
c'est qu'en fait par association le
crâne d'arbine ressemble énormément à un
autre crâne qui a été découvert dans les
années 70 et qui qui a été découvert
aussi en chine et qui s'appelle le crâne
de dali et ce crâne de dali à l'époque
dans les années 70 il lui en donner le
nom de homo dali m6 donc l'homme de dali
littéralement donc le crâne de dali
ressemble énormément au kram d'arbine
les comparaisons anatomique et l'article
de 2021 dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
associe le crâne d'arbine avec le crâne
de dali ce qui veut dire que par voie de
priorité nomenclature aller la loi de
priorité nomenclature halle est une des
lois les plus inviolable du code de
nomenclature le par voie de priorité
nomenclature al en réalité au mot longhi
devrait être homo d'alien 6 donc daly le
crâne de dali devrait être le crâne de
référence pour homologuer donc homologué
disparaît devient synonyme de homo
d'alien 6 mai comme homos l'ong y est
associée à l'homme de denisova rappelez
vous
ça veut dire que l'homme de denisova en
fait c'est au mode ali n 6 mais là où ça
va vous faire siffler le cocotier et là
où ça va bouleverser à peu près tout ce
qu'on croyait savoir sur l'homme de
denisova bas c'est qu'en fait comme je
les dis le crâne de dali on le connaît
depuis les années 70 mais le crâne
d'arbine ça fait depuis 1933 qu'on l'a
découvert la découverte du crâne
d'arbine elle remonte à 1933 ça fait
presque un siècle que l'homme de
denisova s'il s'agit bien de l'homme de
denisova ça fait un siècle que l'homme
de denisova il est sous notre pi fait
qu'on est incapable de le reconnaître et
ça ça démontre bien l'importance de la
multidisciplinarité de la paléontologie
la paléontologie s'est pas seulement de
la morphologie s'est pas seulement de la
géologie c'est aussi de la
paléogénétique et c'est la combinaison
de tous ces indices des analyses
génétiques d'un côté des analyses
morphologiques de l'autre c'est cette
combinaison qui permet d'identifier
harbin et dali comme appartenant à
denisova et c'est cette combinaison qui
permet de montrer qu'en fait ça fait
plusieurs décennies qu'on avait des
crânes de denisova et depuis 2010 on se
demande à quoi denisova ressemble alors
que s'écrasent et elle a su notre pif et
c'est la multidisciplinarité de la
paléontologie et de la paléogénétique
qui ont permis l'identification de cette
découverte majeure donc voilà j'espère
que cette petite mise au point sur
l'homme de denisova vous a plu et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut